Narrator:
LifeMed HAS AN ENTIRE FLEET
RANGING FROM LEARJETS
TO CESSNAS.
BUT ONLY ONE OF THEIR EMERGENCY
AIRCRAFT CAN MANEUVER ITS WAY
INTO THE TOUGHEST-TO-REACH
TERRAIN OF SOUTH-CENTRAL ALASKA.
IT MEASURES IN AT 42 FEET,
THE LENGTH
OF AN AVERAGE SCHOOL BUS.
IT TOPS OUT
AT 178 MILES PER HOUR,
NEARLY 20 MILES PER HOUR FASTER
THAN AN AVERAGE HELICOPTER.
I WOULD DESCRIBE IT
AS THE SPORTS CAR
OF THE HELICOPTER WORLD.
Narrator: THIS IS THE
A-STAR 350 B2 HELICOPTER.
THE A-STAR IS EQUIPPED
WITH AN I.V. INFUSION SYSTEM
THAT CAN RUN THREE SEPARATE
I.V.s TO A PATIENT AT ONCE.
A LIQUID OXYGEN SYSTEM
HOLDS MORE THAN 30 TIMES
THE OXYGEN BY VOLUME
THAN AN AVERAGE TANK.
Woman: THIS LITTLE, TINY BALL
CAN ACTUALLY HOLD
LIKE SIX HOURS WORTH OF OXYGEN.
Narrator: THE DEFIBRILLATOR
HOLDS ENOUGH CHARGE
TO BE USED
FOR SIX HOURS AT A TIME.
THEY SHOCK THE GUY,
AND THEY'LL BE DOING CPR,
AND YOU CAN FEEL
THE WHOLE HELICOPTER MOVE.
Narrator:
AND A HEAVY-DUTY PORTABLE
STRETCHER CALLED THE MEGAMOVER
CAN LIFT NEARLY THE WEIGHT
OF A POLAR BEAR.
WHILE THE INSIDE OF THE A-STAR
IS BUILT LIKE AN I.C.U.,
THE OUTSIDE IS BUILT TO TACKLE
ALASKA'S EXTREME ELEMENTS.
THE MAIN FEATURE ON THE A-STAR
ARE THESE BEARPAWS
OR TUNDRA SHOES.
JUST GIVE THE HELICOPTER
A LITTLE BIT OF FLOAT.
Narrator: MADE FROM LIGHTWEIGHT,
HIGH-PERFORMANCE POLYMER,
BEARPAWS WORK THE SAME WAY
AS SNOWSHOES.
THEIR WIDE BASE
EVENLY DISTRIBUTES THE A-STAR'S
WEIGHT UPON LANDING.
THIS PREVENTS
THE HEAVIEST SECTION, THE TAIL,
FROM SPIKING INTO THE GROUND
OR SINKING INTO DEEP SNOW.